looks
very very nice on you martha thank you
here why don't you take that
late night i must say it is great to be
back o'brien ladies and gentlemen
have a seat right here i mean you're in
the house we got the people and of
course the seat
she'll provide a nice uh comfortable
seat for my uh
oversized baby bottom posterior well uh
that's what however you refer to your
bottom as my oversized baby bottom
posterior well you got to keep it clean
for a mooning incidence and whatnot uh
you know what you're a very humble man
carrying this around wherever you go
i love it you try to stay low-key i love
you walk into a 7-eleven i'll have a
slushie what oh this
i didn't even know it was there a little
thing i guess i won
i have to say there's a lot there i'm
fascinated by your job it's let's face
it it's very
uh different from what i do it's a
circus uh yeah
well if there's some similarities we
both have to be in fantastic physical
shape
but then the similarities start to go
away now one of the things that you that
seems to be very important in your job
and i've noticed this a lot with who
you're very good at is the stare down
you know what when wrestlers get in the
ring there's that moment where they're
just looking at each other and you're
very good at it
it's a big thing i mean there's a lot of
intimidating characters in our
profession and you have to have
the stare down oh look at that yeah
that's pretty intense
let me try that do you think i could i
mean do you think i have the ability
people to to take you on in the old
classic stare down would you be
intimidated by me let's try it right now
you see before a match
yeah hold on and get my hair just right
that's that would be bad what i'm doing
right now is probably be bad that's
not very intimidating yeah okay let's
try right now and one two three
go
why can't i quit you
your favorite time
i was you could probably see little
hearts coming out of my head
they were very good at that uh now you
you have us every
wrestler likes to have their signature
moves absolutely what's one of your
signature moves in the ring that you
could tell us about
believe it or not i have uh a bevy of
them one of them is called the fu which
you saw on that large gentleman in the
velvet
couch how heavy is that man but who is
that man who is that
that is the world's largest love machine
viscera
visceral and he clocks in at about 550
pounds
you you lifted him over your head
yes and it was like trying to transport
a waterbed
yeah it was
fascinating i noticed after you threw
him down his belly went
it was a it was it was an event uh
incredible so you slam this guy down
that's one of the moves
and i i love that that's that's not a
move you can teach to someone because
one of the things you need to be able to
do is lift 550 pounds over here yeah
that's that's the entry level so there's
no way you're gonna teach me that move
no no okay i could lift like an old old
man maybe i could get him about chest
high and then push him
that's not gonna do much and then he'd
push me back and i'd run away
yeah that's not gonna do much